everyone's going to want to see Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker but some fans
will need to exercise a little extra
caution Disney is working with the
Epilepsy Foundation to get the word out
that viewers with photosensitive
epilepsy may be adversely affected by
some sequences in the movie those with
photosensitive epilepsy a group which
comprises about 3% of epilepsy patients
overall can suffer seizures when exposed
to strobe like flashing lights for
significant periods of time as a result
the House of mouse has reportedly sent a
letter to every venue exhibiting the
rise of skywalker
all over the world warning of the
potential of some portions of the film
to cause serious problems for viewers
with the condition at the same time the
Epilepsy Foundation official Twitter
account tweeted a message
praising Disney for its proactive stance
and sharing a link to a page on its
website containing advice for
photosensitive epilepsy sufferers who
like the rest of us are anxiously
awaiting the flicks release this is
important info which we'll share for the
benefit of anyone who suffers from
photosensitive epilepsy or know somebody
who does
the Foundation's helpful message comes
with advice for viewers who may suffer
from photosensitive epilepsy but still
want to safely see the movie medical
concerns are not the message reads in
part if you or someone you know are
sensitive to lights please consider the
following as you make plans to watch the
movie ask a friend to watch the movie
first take your friend with you when you
go to see the film to alert you to which
scenes contain the flashing lights so
you can block your eyes during those
scenes teach your friend the three
simple steps of seizure first aid stay
safe side so that they can assist you if
you have a seizure about those three
steps in the event that someone your
width has an epileptic seizure you'll
want to stay with the person and start
timing the seizure make sure that
they're safe steering them clear of
potentially dangerous objects or
environments and turn them on their side
to help make them as comfortable as
possible you can visit the epilepsy
foundation's first aid for seizures page
on its website for more information
one of the last major pictures to pose
significant risks to those suffering
from photosensitive epilepsy was
Incredibles 2
the highly anticipated sequel to Pixar's
2004 superhero spectacular that film
ended up carrying a similar warning to
the rise of Skywalker's at some theaters
for its overseas and home releases
Disney went so far as to re-edit the
film so that it would comply with the
Harding box test which is used to
effectively measure the risk posed to
photosensitive epilepsy sufferers due to
flashing lights 2011 s Twilight Breaking
Dawn Part 1 is another major mainstream
film which prompted a warning from the
Epilepsy Foundation after nine
moviegoers were reported to have been
hospitalized during screenings the
tumblr page movie health community which
keeps track of films which might pose
problems for those with epilepsy or
acute motion sickness has also compiled
a list of recent films which may prompt
epileptic seizures
among them are oceans 8 solo a Star Wars
story a wrinkle and time
Deadpool 2 ready player one Avengers
infinity war Tomb Raider and the Netflix
movie the Cloverfield paradox while it's
only a small percentage of the
population that are adversely affected
by exposure to flashing lights it's safe
to say that pretty much everybody is
going to be taking in the rise of
skywalker at some point so it's only
appropriate that the potential risk to
that subset of viewers should be
broadcast loud and clear we're all in
this
all too often giant corporations are
oblivious to the issues that their
products might cause to underrepresented
segments of their customer bases so when
they get things right we're of the
opinion that they should be commended in
this case Disney absolutely got it right
so thank you Mickey for doing your part
to prevent any unnecessary suffering on
the part of viewers who can't wait to
see how the decade spanning Skywalker
saga ends check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the belt so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]